Knock knock. No, I guess you can't say. So I'll do okay. I'll play both. Knock knock. Who's there? Smartless. Smartless who?
敲敲门。不，我想你不能说。所以我来吧。我两个都演。敲敲门。谁在那儿？Smartless。Smartless是谁？
It's an all new Smartless. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
这是一个全新的Smartless。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. I realize that I think that I curse too much. You do? Yeah. What are you fucking talking about? There we go. Wait, really? Why do you say that? I don't think you do. Because don't you fucking talking about?
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。我意识到我好像骂人太多了。你觉得吗？是啊。你他妈在说什么？这就对了。等等，真的吗？你为什么这么说？我不觉得你骂人多。因为你他妈在说什么？
Wait, really? Why do you say that? Don't you think I do? I feel like I do. It just occurred to me that I feel like I curse too much. I think not enough. Did you get that feeling because you were hanging out with your dad and you caught yourself a couple of times? No, truly. Where did this thought come from? You caught yourself a couple of times? No, truly, where did this thought come from?
等等，真的吗？你为什么这么说？你不觉得我骂人多吗？我觉得我骂得挺多的。我刚才突然想到，我觉得我骂人太多了。我觉得还不够多。你是因为和你爸爸待在一起，发现自己说了几次脏话才会有这种感觉吗？不，真的。这个想法是从哪儿来的？你发现自己说了几次脏话？不，真的，这个想法是从哪儿来的？
I think I was talking about hockey with somebody the other day and I realized that especially when I talk about hockey, I'm like, these fucking guys and look at this fucking team. And I saw this review of some gadget that somebody, that they've just released, some AI gadget that documents the words that you say throughout the course of a day or a week or a month, et cetera, and this woman was talking about how much she had heard she was cursing,
我想前几天我和某人谈论曲棍球时，我意识到，特别是在谈论曲棍球时，我会说，这些他妈的家伙，看看这支他妈的球队。我看到有人发布了一个小工具的评论，就是那种AI小工具，可以记录你一天、一周或一个月内所说的话，那个女人在谈论她听到自己骂了多少次，
and I was like, I wonder how much I curse. Really? Yeah, a little bit. It used to be my, if I got nervous, I used to swear a lot. Like the very first time I met Steven Spielberg in his office. Oh no.
我就想，我不知道自己骂了多少次。真的吗？是啊，一点点。以前如果我紧张，我就会骂很多脏话。就像我第一次在办公室见到史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格的时候。哦，不。
All I did, every other word was fuck. What? I was like, yeah, and his kids were playing video games. I was like, oh, that's fucking cool. When did you fucking get that? That's fucking amazing. I couldn't stop saying it. I remember I once had a,
我所做的，每隔一个词就是“他妈的”。什么？我说，是啊，他的孩子们在玩电子游戏。我说，哦，那真是他妈的酷。你他妈什么时候弄到的？那真是他妈的太棒了。我停不下来。我记得我曾经有一次，
the guy who wrote and directed, I think he wrote, but he definitely directed Napoleon Dynamite, this guy Jared has, he's a great director. Yeah, amazing, he's great. And I got a meeting with him just after Napoleon Dynamite, I was so excited, and just like, I get lazy with cursing, it's just like,
那个写并导演了《拿破仑炸药》的人，我想他写了剧本，但他绝对是导演，这个叫杰瑞德的家伙，他是一位伟大的导演。是啊，太棒了，他很棒。我在《拿破仑炸药》之后和他有个会面，我太兴奋了，就像，我骂人变得懒散了，这就像，
sort of like a way to bond, you know? Yeah, that's what I'm saying, yeah, right. And so I'm just like every word is this, and that fuck, and that blah, blah, blah. And I'm driving home and I call my agent. I say, oh, the meeting went really, really well. And he goes, you know, I was going to say something. I was wondering if it did,
算是一种建立联系的方式，你知道吗？是啊，这就是我想说的，没错。所以我说的每个词都是这个，那个他妈的，还有那些乱七八糟的。我在开车回家的路上给我经纪人打电话。我说，哦，会面进行得非常非常顺利。他说，你知道，我本来想说点什么的。我当时就在想是不是真的顺利，
because I know your family lived in Salt Lake City for a few years, and I was wondering if your family had any Mormonism in their background. Did you guys talk about Mormonism? Because you know, he's a big, big Mormon. Oh, I didn't know that. And I'm like, oh no. Because then I started, like,
因为我知道你们家在盐湖城住了几年，我在想你们家是否有摩门教背景。你们谈论摩门教了吗？因为你知道，他是个大摩门教徒。哦，我不知道。我就想，哦，不。因为那时我开始，就像，
then I was flashing back to the meeting, so I'm driving home like, yeah, he didn't say anything that was off color. And of course, I never heard from this guy yet. I'll feel, I was to this day. To this day, have you spoken to him? anything that was off color. And of course I never heard from this guy yet. I'll feel about it. To this day, have you spoken to him? To this day, no.
那时我回想起那次会面，所以我开车回家时想，是啊，他没说什么不得体的话。当然，我再也没收到那个人的消息。我到现在还在想。直到今天，你和他谈过吗？不得体的话。当然，我再也没收到那个人的消息。我对此感到……直到今天，你和他谈过吗？直到今天，没有。
I probably was just deeply offensive to him. That's so funny. We gotta get him on here and ask him about that. I'm sure he didn't even notice. Well, I don't know. That's funny. I tell you what. This is a segue, Sean.
我可能对他非常冒犯。太搞笑了。我们得把他请来问问他这件事。我敢肯定他甚至没注意到。好吧，我不知道。那很有趣。我告诉你。这是一个过渡，肖恩。
This is a segue. Incredible, it's so what. This is a segue, Sean. This is a segue. Incredible, it's so smooth. This is a segue. And my guest, my guest is, you know, we all like cool things and we like being, feeling like that we're part of, you know, that we're up on culture, that we're up on what's going on in the world.
这是一个过渡。不可思议，太顺了。这是一个过渡，肖恩。这是一个过渡。不可思议，太顺了。这是一个过渡。而我的嘉宾，我的嘉宾是，你知道，我们都喜欢酷的东西，我们喜欢感觉自己是其中的一部分，你知道，我们紧跟文化，我们紧跟世界上正在发生的事情。
This is a guy who's been not only at the forefront, but I think, I would dare to say, been shaping it for many years. He happens to be- Yon Winner? Oh. He happens to be from my home- Is it Yon Winner?
这是一个不仅走在最前沿，而且我敢说，多年来一直在塑造它的人。他恰好是——扬·温纳？哦。他恰好来自我的家乡——是扬·温纳吗？
It's Canada? Yon Winner's not Canadian. Are you sure? I'm very sure that Yon Winner's not Canadian. Okay. He, you didn't know him when he was in Canada, but he'd started a magazine in 1973 called the Canadian Review that was very popular.
是加拿大吗？扬·温纳不是加拿大人。你确定吗？我非常确定扬·温纳不是加拿大人。好吧。他，你在加拿大时并不认识他，但他1973年创办了一本名为《加拿大评论》的杂志，非常受欢迎。
He then moved to the States and he worked for Time Magazine. He worked for a bunch of other things, Life Magazine. And then in 1986, he co-founded a very, very popular and influential magazine known as Spy Magazine. This is not Graydon Carter? Left that in great shape. It is Graydon Carter. It went on to become over 25 years
后来他搬到了美国，为《时代》杂志工作。他还为其他很多东西工作过，比如《生活》杂志。然后在1986年，他联合创办了一本非常非常受欢迎且有影响力的杂志，叫《间谍》杂志。这不是格雷登·卡特吗？留下了很好的基础。就是格雷登·卡特。他后来成为了超过25年的
the editor of Vanity Fair. He's got a new book coming out called When the Going Was Good Guys, it's Graydon Carter. Nice. Good morning sir. I read the airmail email this morning. Bless you. Yes, you didn't mention airmail, sir. I read the Air Mail email this morning. Bless you. Yes, you didn't mention Air Mail, Willie.
《名利场》的主编。他有一本新书要出版，叫《当日子好过的时候》，伙计们，是格雷登·卡特。不错。早上好，先生。我今天早上读了《航空邮件》的电子邮件。保佑你。是的，你没提到《航空邮件》，先生。我今天早上读了《航空邮件》的电子邮件。保佑你。是的，你没提到《航空邮件》，威利。
I know, well I was about to get to Air Mail because you kept saying Graydon Carter so I was like trying to get through it. This is an awesome guest. I know. Nice going, Will. Welcome, Graydon, and I mentioned all the various things that you did that you started.
我知道，好吧，我正要提到《航空邮件》，因为你一直说格雷登·卡特，所以我试图把它说完。这是一位很棒的嘉宾。我知道。干得好，威尔。欢迎，格雷登，我提到了你所做的各种事情，你创办的那些。
You started as a young writer and you founded, how old were you when you founded the Canadian Review? What was that in 1973? I was 23. That takes a lot of, I was going to say guts, but it takes a lot of chutzpah to start a magazine when you're 23 years old. Wow, how do you even start?
你作为一名年轻作家起步，你创办了，你创办《加拿大评论》时多大？那是1973年吗？我23岁。那需要很多，我本来想说胆量，但这需要很多勇气才能在23岁时创办一本杂志。哇，你甚至是怎么开始的？
How do you get there? How do you know where to start? I actually didn't start it. I bumped into a bunch of guys who were starting it in college and they needed an art director and I said, well, I can draw and they said, well, one should be the art director. And then little magazines are just festering pits
你怎么到达那里的？你怎么知道从哪里开始？其实我并没有创办它。我在大学里碰巧遇到了一群正在创办它的人，他们需要一位艺术总监，我说，好吧，我会画画，他们说，好吧，那你就当艺术总监吧。然后小杂志只是充满
of bitterness and jealousy and envy. And so one by one, they all left and then I became the editor. And it wasn't as good as Will was pointing out. He was being very kind about it. Nobody knew what they were doing. And that was completely evident to readers and advertisers that we were completely incompetent.
苦涩、嫉妒和羡慕的温床。所以他们一个接一个地离开了，然后我成了主编。它并不像威尔指出的那么好。他当时说得很客气。没人知道自己在做什么。这对读者和广告商来说完全显而易见，我们完全是不称职的。
But it did lead to a job at Time Magazine when Time Magazine was like probably one of the most important magazines on the planet. Yeah, and what did you do there at Time? I was a writer, but you know, this was 1978. The city was still teetering after bankruptcy and was dangerous and there were burnt out cars everywhere, but rents were really cheap and And I lived in Greenwich Village.
但它确实让我得到了一份在《时代》杂志的工作，当时《时代》杂志可能是地球上最重要的杂志之一。是啊，你在《时代》杂志做了什么？我是一名作家，但你知道，那是1978年。这座城市在破产后仍然摇摇欲坠，很危险，到处都是烧毁的汽车，但租金真的很便宜，我住在格林威治村。
My first apartment was about a block and a half away from here. And it was $200 a month, and it had high ceilings and a garden. But then when I got to time, they were restocking it with a bunch of young writers. And there was people like Walter Oskarsohn, who became the great biographer.
我的第一间公寓离这里大约一个半街区。每月200美元，有高高的天花板和一个花园。但后来我到了《时代》，他们正在招募一批年轻作家。有像沃尔特·艾萨克森这样的人，他后来成为了伟大的传记作家。
There was Michiko Kakutani, who became the chief book critic with the New York Times for 35 years, Frank Rich, who became the theater critic with the New York Times, and then the producer of Succession, and Maureen Dowd, who was there, Rick Stengel, who became the editor of Time, my best friend Jim Kelly, who became the editor of Time. Anyway, it was just a remarkable period
还有美智子·角谷，她后来成为了《纽约时报》35年的首席书评人；弗兰克·里奇，他成为了《纽约时报》的戏剧评论家，后来是《继承之战》的制片人；还有莫琳·多德，当时也在那里；里克·斯坦格尔，后来成为了《时代》的主编；我最好的朋友吉姆·凯利，后来也成为了《时代》的主编。总之，那是一个非凡的时期，
and we were all still keeping touch with each other. And it was very intimidating for me because I thought, wait a minute, are all Americans this smart? And thankfully they're not. Well, that's true. You're talking to three of them. There you go.
我们至今仍保持着联系。这对我来说非常令人生畏，因为我想，等一下，所有的美国人都这么聪明吗？谢天谢地，他们不是。好吧，那是真的。你正在和其中的三个说话。这就对了。
Exactly. Well, two and a half. You guys are the smartest. Yeah. Yeah. That's amazing. And so you work at Time Magazine with all this great talent,
没错。好吧，两个半。你们是最聪明的。是啊。是啊。太神奇了。所以你在《时代》杂志和所有这些伟大的人才一起工作，
and then you and Kurt Anderson form Spy Magazine, which, boy, I remember Spy Magazine and a lot of people do. It was so, it's been described as like, as sort of like vicious and cruel, but also like really dead on. And you sort of, somebody quoted something like, you despised all the right people.
然后你和库尔特·安德森创办了《间谍》杂志，天哪，我记得《间谍》杂志，很多人都记得。它太，它被描述为有点恶毒和残忍，但也真的很精准。你有点，有人引用过类似的话，你鄙视所有正确的人。
Well, you know, there was a, there was the time all of a sudden in the mid 1980s, New York had sort of come alive financially. And, you know, investment banks had been sort of invented and that meant there were investment bankers around and they already had a lot of money and they loved showing it off. And accidentally, I think our timing was wonderful.
嗯，你知道，在1980年代中期，纽约在经济上突然活跃起来。而且，你知道，投资银行被发明出来了，这意味着周围有很多投资银行家，他们已经很有钱了，而且他们喜欢炫耀。偶然地，我认为我们的时机非常好。
And we used to call it a stringent rather than mean. Stringent. But you know, that, it did occupy a space of sort of, I don't know what the term might be, sort of a healthy cynicism and a, you know, like David Spade had, we've talked about it a few times on this show, he had a segment on Saturday Night Live,
我们过去称它为严厉而不是刻薄。严厉。但你知道，它确实占据了一种，我不知道该怎么形容，一种健康的愤世嫉俗，你知道，就像大卫·斯佩德，我们在节目中谈过几次，他在《周六夜现场》有一个环节，
I think it was called The Hollywood Minute, where you'd kind of watch through your fingers, you know, sort of like you didn't want to see it or hear it, but it was always so accurate. And- And funny. I don't know what point I'm making, but I guess I want to say that there,
我想叫《好莱坞一分钟》，你会透过手指看，你知道，就像你不想看或听，但它总是那么准确。而且——而且有趣。我不知道我想表达什么，但我猜我想说的是，
I don't know if it's unique to this country. You feel that it's gone or no? No, I don't. I feel like there is a space somewhere for people having the balls to call out that, which is kind of apparent to all of us, yet only discussed in quiet circles with your closest friends, yet everybody says it. You just don't say it in a big group.
我不知道这是否是这个国家独有的。你觉得它消失了吗？不，我不觉得。我觉得在某个地方仍然有空间让人们有胆量去指出那些对我们所有人来说都很明显，却只在与最亲密朋友的私下圈子里讨论，但每个人都这么说的事情。你只是不在大群体中说出来。
You say it in small groups. You're just calling out accuracies on people's foibles. And it is interesting and maybe healthy. I guess this is the question. What do you guys think? Is it healthy to have mainstream media, to have a place in mainstream media for that type of release?
你在小群体中说。你只是在指出人们怪癖的准确性。这很有趣，也许很健康。我想这就是问题所在。你们怎么看？在主流媒体中为这种释放留出空间是健康的吗？
I mean, look at people like John Oliver and Seth Meyers and their news elements, and they do it better almost than, they do do it better than the evening news in a certain way. You know, not everything is objective. If you're talking about the earth being round, they do it better than the evening news in a certain way. Not everything is objective. If you're talking about the earth being round, you don't need somebody from the Flat Earth Society
我是说，看看像约翰·奥利弗和塞斯·梅耶斯这样的人，以及他们的新闻元素，他们做得几乎比，他们确实比晚间新闻做得更好。你知道，并非一切都是客观的。如果你在谈论地球是圆的，他们做得比晚间新闻更好。并非一切都是客观的。如果你在谈论地球是圆的，你不需要来自地平协会的人
to come out and give the counter argument. All right, but Jason's, I think maybe, I don't want to put words in your mouth, but maybe you're talking about insults. Well, yeah, but that cynicism that exists in some corners of mainstream media, like, I don't know if this is fair, because I'm not a student of all this, but I feel like Vulture on the New York Magazine,
出来给出反驳论点。好吧，但杰森的，我想也许，我不想替你说话，但也许你在谈论侮辱。嗯，是的，但那种存在于主流媒体某些角落的愤世嫉俗，就像，我不知道这是否公平，因为我不是这方面的学生，但我觉得《纽约杂志》的《秃鹫》栏目，
they sometimes, they even have a hot radar, they've got a term for it, and they just call out basically what everyone's talking about in sort of, I put in quotes, the cool circles. And I mention it only because it does seem to drive some pop culture successes and create some pop culture failures when it's discussed at sort of that,
他们有时，他们甚至有热门雷达，他们有一个术语，他们基本上只是指出每个人在，我加引号，酷圈子里谈论的事情。我提到它只是因为它似乎确实推动了一些流行文化的成功，并在以那种方式讨论时制造了一些流行文化的失败，
again in quotes, that high level, and then it sort of filters out into less cynical parts of our country and our media. It drives like what films get seen. I mean, it's sort of the theory of like having critics. You know, it's like one person says something is good, and then that starts to disseminate, and then it actually forms a wave of either success
再次加引号，那种高水平，然后它会过滤到我们国家和媒体中不那么愤世嫉俗的部分。它驱动了哪些电影被观看。我的意思是，这有点像拥有评论家的理论。你知道，就像一个人说某事是好的，然后它开始传播，然后它实际上形成了一波成功
or failure for some things. And I wonder if that is a healthy thing that we should have in media. My guess would be yes, but it's hurtful. But at the same time, you know, like everybody, excuse me, on the internet, everybody's a critic. Yeah. It's a sewer by and large.
或失败。我想知道这是否是我们应该在媒体中拥有的健康事物。我的猜测是是的，但它很伤人。但与此同时，你知道，就像每个人，对不起，在互联网上，每个人都是评论家。是啊。总的来说，那是个下水道。
But if you have people who have proper opinions and they're within the realms of accuracy, it can make a good difference. And the internet, word of mouth, is the most powerful tool in the world. And the internet just lets it grow exponentially rather than arithmetically. Well, the problem is though,
但如果你有拥有正确观点的人，并且他们在准确性的范围内，它可以产生很好的影响。而互联网，口碑，是世界上最强大的工具。互联网只是让它呈指数级增长，而不是算术级增长。好吧，问题在于，
with the internet and with social media, is that often some of these voices all come at the same volume, and volume that they don't deserve. And so things get lost in the shuffle. But Jason, I think you were referring to the approval matrix, right, that they do. And there was something about Spire that did that,
随着互联网和社交媒体的发展，这些声音往往以相同的音量出现，而且是它们不应得的音量。所以事情在混乱中丢失了。但杰森，我想你指的是他们做的“批准矩阵”，对吧？《间谍》杂志确实做过类似的事情，
which was, which is it just held things up to a light and sort of brought them into focus a little bit, things that, I remember there was a piece you guys did, you probably don't even remember this, but there was a piece you did, you may have already left, but it was certainly really tonally right in line with the kind of thing that you had set forth at Spy, which was they had a woman holding a pair of roller blades
那就是，它只是把事情放在光线下，让它们稍微聚焦一点，那些，我记得你们做过一篇报道，你可能都不记得了，但那是一篇报道，你可能已经离开了，但它在基调上确实与你在《间谍》杂志所设定的那种东西非常一致，那就是他们让一个女人拿着一副轮滑鞋
over her shoulder, and they had her go to different neighborhoods of the city to see what reactions she'd get in different reactions. They put her on the Upper West Side, Upper East Side, flat iron, downtown, and what people would say to her at different street corners. And the Upper East Side goes like, do you like to skate in the park?. On the Upper East Side, I was like, do you like to skate in the park?
扛在肩上，让他们带她去城市的不同街区，看看她在不同地方会得到什么反应。他们把她放在上西区、上东区、熨斗区、市中心，以及人们在不同街角会对她说什么。上东区的人就像，你喜欢在公园里滑冰吗？在上东区，我就像，你喜欢在公园里滑冰吗？
And then the Upper West Side, the guy's like, hey, you look great, why don't you put those down, let's go get a drink. And then in flat iron, the guy's like, why won't you talk to me, bitch? And you know. Lower East Side is get the fuck out of my face. And that's the kind of thing that,
然后上西区，那家伙就像，嘿，你看上去很棒，为什么不把那些放下，我们去喝一杯。然后在熨斗区，那家伙就像，你为什么不跟我说话，婊子？你知道的。下东区就是滚出我的视线。这就是那种，
I do think that that sort of thing is missing because everybody is so nervous. Yes, that's the kind of thing that I do think that that sort of thing is missing because everybody is so nervous about offending and also everybody is so quick to be offended and this is gonna get, I hope this will be a pull quote about me railing against people being offended. But there was a notion back there of like, I don't give a shit if you're offended, who cares?
我确实认为那种事情缺失了，因为每个人都太紧张了。是的，这就是那种我确实认为缺失的事情，因为每个人都对冒犯别人太紧张了，而且每个人都太容易被冒犯了，这会变成，我希望这会成为关于我抨击人们容易被冒犯的摘录。但当时有一种观念，就像，我不在乎你是否被冒犯，谁在乎呢？
As long as I'm not hurting anybody or saying this completely, I'm offended, okay. Yeah, there's a healthy space for that too that I feel has been lacking in the last few years as we needed to make and are still working on this sort of correction for those that are marginalized. But I think the consensus is starting to come out that maybe there was an over-correction
只要我没有伤害任何人或说这个完全，我被冒犯了，好吧。是的，那里也有一个健康的生存空间，我觉得在过去几年里一直缺失，因为我们需要做出，并且仍在努力为那些被边缘化的人进行这种修正。但我认为共识开始出现，也许存在过度修正，
and it's starting to come back to middle a little bit now. And so there's a healthy level of, hey, listen, offending you is part of the joke or part of this thing. And so there's some casualties that are a part of the joke or part of this thing. And so there's some casualties that are a part of that metric. What do you think about that shift that's going on right now, Graydon?
现在开始稍微回到中间了。所以有一种健康的水平，嘿，听着，冒犯你是笑话的一部分或这件事的一部分。所以有一些伤亡是笑话的一部分或这件事的一部分。你对现在正在发生的这种转变有什么看法，格雷登？
Will and I would know this better because it came from Canada, but the pendulum in America swings in great arcs like this. And in Britain it swings like this, and in Canada it swings like this. So America goes way out, I mean, in the 1960s, you know, the pre-love movement was much further out in America than it was in say in San Francisco
威尔和我对此会更了解，因为它来自加拿大，但美国的钟摆像这样大幅摆动。在英国它像这样摆动，在加拿大它像这样摆动。所以美国走得很远，我的意思是，在1960年代，你知道，预爱运动在美国比在，比如说旧金山，
than it was in Toronto. And, but then it swings right back. So in the 1980s, the investment banker ethos was much more pronounced in New York than it was in Vancouver, say. So America is these, it just has larger swings and so the extremes are greater. And I think it is coming, it will come,
比在多伦多要远得多。但是，它又摆了回来。所以到了1980年代，投资银行家的精神在纽约比在温哥华要明显得多。所以美国是这些，它只是有更大的摆动，所以极端情况更大。而且我认为它正在到来，它会到来，
it's a correction from the far left and then it's gone, went way too far to the far right and it will settle somewhere in the middle. You just hope that it does sooner rather than later. I think it will. Yeah, and of course, nobody's advocating for the marginalization of people who are different at all, and that's never been,
这是从极左的修正，然后它消失了，走得太远到了极右，它会停在中间的某个地方。你只是希望它早点到来而不是晚点。我想会的。是啊，当然，没有人主张边缘化与众不同的人，那从来都不是，
I think that anybody, certainly all of us, I would assume none of us would ever advocate for that. But I must say, it makes sense for someone who likes to comment on culture and whose writing and whose profession is informed by that. Of course, moving to the States is a natural progression for you, right? Because you've-
我想任何人，当然我们所有人，我假设我们中没有人会主张那样。但我必须说，对于一个喜欢评论文化，且其写作和职业受此影响的人来说，这很有意义。当然，搬到美国对你来说是一个自然的进程，对吧？因为你已经——
And you, yes. And me as well, of course, yeah. Because there is that ceiling in Canada where you can only go so far, unfortunately. It's a great place to be from. It's a great place to live still. I'm not suggesting anything otherwise. I love Canada.
还有你，是的。当然还有我。因为在加拿大确实有那个天花板，不幸的是你只能走那么远。那是一个很好的出身地。它仍然是一个很好的居住地。我不是在暗示别的。我爱加拿大。
Keep going, Will, yeah, you gotta put out the fire. Yeah. You're offending somebody here, yes. I am definitely offending somebody. How far have I dug now? Can I even see the top of the hole that I'm in? Yeah. You know, I've told that story before,
继续，威尔，是啊，你得把火扑灭。是啊。你在这里冒犯了某人，是的。我绝对是在冒犯某人。我现在挖了多深了？我甚至能看到我所在的洞的顶部吗？是啊。你知道，我以前讲过那个故事，
the difference between the Canadian lobster fisherman and the American lobster fisherman, right? What is it? They're walking on the road after their day of lobster fishing and the American lobster fisherman says to the Canadian, he says, I notice you don't have a top on your pot thereby, aren't you worried about your lobsters getting out?
加拿大龙虾渔民和美国龙虾渔民之间的区别，对吧？是什么？他们在龙虾捕捞一天后走在路上，美国龙虾渔民对加拿大人说，我注意到你的锅上没有盖子，你不担心你的龙虾跑出来吗？
And the Canadian says, no, these here are Canadian lobsters. If one of them tries to get out, the other ones will pull them back down. That's great, that's great. And there's an element of truth to that. But moving to the States and starting Spy Magazine and then moving to Vanity Fair, which has an even greater audience
加拿大人说，不，这些是加拿大龙虾。如果其中一只试图爬出来，其他的会把它拉回去。太棒了，太棒了。这其中有真实的成分。但搬到美国并创办《间谍》杂志，然后搬到《名利场》，它拥有更大的受众，
and even sort of a broader demographic, if you will, that must have been, you must have been very excited at the prospect of kind of opening up a huge demo to what you wanted to say and what you thought was important to talk about. Yeah, and talk about having a piece of media that anoints week to week, or was it month to month?
甚至可以说更广泛的人口统计，如果可以这么说的话，那一定，你一定对能够向你想说的话和你想谈论的重要事情开放一个巨大的受众群体感到非常兴奋。是啊，谈谈拥有一个每周，或者是一个月一次的媒体？
I think it was month to month. Who is it? You know, you and Lorne Michaels were basically, had the two levers that existed on putting people. Two Canadians, by the way. Two Canadians here, yeah. Putting people on top of the mountain at your discretion, which was pretty incredible.
我想是一个月一次。是谁？你知道，你和洛恩·迈克尔斯基本上，掌握着决定人们命运的两个杠杆。顺便说一句，两个加拿大人。这里有两个加拿大人，是啊。由你决定把人放在山顶上，这真是太不可思议了。
I didn't, it's funny, looking back, and I realize some of what you say is, it was evident to others, it never was to me. It was a matter of survival for the most part. I wanted to, I had a lot of children, and I wanted to, I had to feed them, and clothe them, and educate them. And so when I got to Venice,
我没有，很有趣，回顾过去，我意识到你所说的一些事情，对别人来说是显而易见的，对我来说从来都不是。这在很大程度上是一个生存问题。我想，我有很多孩子，我想，我必须喂养他们，给他们穿衣，教育他们。所以当我到达《名利场》时，
I was the least popular person to get there because we had spent five years at Spy making fun of the editor, of the house writing style, of many of the contributors. So when I walked in, it was funereal, the whole mood of the place. And I didn't fire anybody for two years, but I eventually, there was, most of the people,
我是最不受欢迎的人，因为我们在《间谍》杂志花了五年时间取笑主编、写作风格、许多撰稿人。所以当我走进去时，整个地方的气氛就像葬礼一样。我两年没解雇任何人，但我最终，有，大多数人，
some of the people were left over just to talk about my inadequacies as they went around to dinner parties in New York. And so I, but I let everybody stay for two years, I thought I'd give them a chance to come around my way of thinking. And then I got rid of these three troublemakers in one week after being there for two years.
有些人留下来只是为了在纽约的晚宴上谈论我的无能。所以我，但我让每个人都留了两年，我想我会给他们一个机会来接受我的思维方式。然后我在两年后的一周内解雇了这三个捣乱分子。
And all of a sudden it shifted and I could bring my children into the opposite bus and it was poisonous and people started saying thank you and please and working together in a collegial way. And because I don't like office drama, I like people to work together. I think you get something better out of it. And then I sort of built it from there
突然间它变了，我可以把我的孩子带到对面的办公室，那里曾经是有毒的，人们开始说谢谢和请，并以一种同事的方式一起工作。因为我不喜欢办公室闹剧，我喜欢人们一起工作。我认为你会从中得到更好的东西。然后我从那里开始建立它，
and I was fortunate to have one of the great owners, Cy Newhouse, who gave me the tools to succeed. He gave me the budget so I could bring in the, I thought, must have been the greatest stable of writers ever. The first writer I brought in was Christopher Hitchens. Wow. Wow, he's great.
我很幸运拥有伟大的所有者之一，赛·纽豪斯，他给了我成功的工具。他给了我预算，所以我可以引入，我想，一定是史上最伟大的作家阵容。我引入的第一个作家是克里斯托弗·希钦斯。哇。哇，他很棒。
Oh, he was heaven. And then also I had photographers like Annie Leibowitz and Helmut Newton and Bruce Weber. So I was blessed by having these incredible colleagues and I was so appreciative of what they did because taking pictures and writing stories is a lot harder work than being an editor. You're just sort of a wage ape,
哦，他简直是天堂。然后我还有像安妮·莱博维茨、赫尔穆特·纽顿和布鲁斯·韦伯这样的摄影师。所以我很幸运能有这些了不起的同事，我非常感谢他们所做的一切，因为拍照和写故事比当主编要辛苦得多。你只是某种工资猿，
and kind of like a cross between a chef and an air traffic controller. And a piece of mold just on your ceiling. We don't really have a point, but other than trying to assemble the thing each month, and anyway, it was just, it was a great perch during one of the greatest periods, but by the was just, it was a great perch during one of the greatest periods, but by the same token, it was a golden age of magazines.
有点像厨师和空中交通管制员的结合体。天花板上还有一块霉菌。我们真的没什么重点，除了试图每个月把东西拼凑起来，总之，这是一个伟大的位置，在最伟大的时期之一，但同样地，这也是杂志的黄金时代。
But one of the reasons, anytime you have a golden age, it's a golden age because everybody is good. So every other editor was firing in all cylinders. All magazines were good in the 1980s and 90s. It was an extraordinary period. And also the magazine business attracted the best and the brightest then. Right.
但原因之一，任何时候你有黄金时代，那是因为每个人都很棒。所以每个其他主编都在全力以赴。1980年代和90年代所有的杂志都很棒。那是一个非凡的时期。而且杂志业务当时吸引了最好和最聪明的人。没错。
Right. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. What was your ethos then when you got there at Vanity Fair, when you sat behind your desk for the first time in those first couple of years and going forward, what was your, did you have an objective, like this is the kind of stuff that I want to do.
没错。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。当你第一次坐在《名利场》的办公桌后，以及未来，你的精神是什么？你有什么目标吗，比如这就是我想做的事情。
Did you have something like that, a plan in mind in a way? Nothing so far, but a sort of an evolving thought that what I wanted to do is every month present the reader with something that is highly, highly compelling that they'll read with and have wonderful stories that could range 15 or 20,000 words, which is the fifth, the size of an average book. And that they would come back the next month.
你有类似那样的计划吗？没什么具体的，但有一个不断演变的想法，我想做的是每个月向读者呈现一些非常非常引人注目的东西，他们会读下去，并有精彩的故事，篇幅可以达到15,000或20,000字，这相当于普通书的五分之一。而且他们下个月还会回来。
I used to write thank you notes to all my contributors every month. Thank you notes to our advertisers who paid for the journalism. The advertising would came in at about $100,000 a page and that sort of, you know, paid for the heat and the light and the electricity. And, but then there was, I got other ideas
我过去每个月都会给我的撰稿人写感谢信。给支付新闻费用的广告商写感谢信。广告费大约是每页10万美元，那，你知道，支付了暖气、灯光和电费。但是后来，我有其他想法，
that really changed the direction of the magazine from, one from David Halberstam to create something called the new establishment, which is the, in the past, the establishments were the head of General Tire and General Motors and a bunch of New York banks. But in the early mid to mid 1990s, America became an entertainment culture and economy. And so what we shipped around the world
真正改变了杂志的方向，一个来自大卫·哈伯斯塔姆，创造了所谓的“新精英”，也就是，在过去，精英是通用轮胎和通用汽车的负责人以及一群纽约银行。但在1990年代初到中期，美国成为了一种娱乐文化和经济。所以我们向世界各地运送的，
weren't cars and tires and things like that. It was intellectual property in terms of like video games and movies and television shows and magazines and technology. And so we did a huge portfolio that Annie shot and it sort of showed the world that there was a new, because there was a new economy, there was a new establishment to that economy.
不是汽车、轮胎之类的东西。而是知识产权，比如电子游戏、电影、电视节目、杂志和技术。所以我们做了一个巨大的投资组合，安妮拍摄了它，它向世界展示了，因为有一个新经济，那个经济就有了一个新精英。
And then doing the Oscar party, which was started off small and terrified that it'd be a failure and it just sort of grew each year. It kind of rivals the Oscars itself in terms of its prestige. As you're well aware, lots of people go, will often just go to the party and not the Oscars themselves.
然后是奥斯卡派对，它开始时很小，很担心会失败，但它每年都在增长。它的声望甚至可以与奥斯卡本身相媲美。正如你所知，很多人去，威尔通常只是去派对而不是奥斯卡本身。
And a lot of people who are big film stars, people, names that everybody, all of us know, and of course the three of us have gone many times and enjoyed that. And it has become its own thing, which is quite miraculous really if you think about it. It's kind of in some ways dethrone the Oscars at its own party in a way. Which, you know, you spoke, you mentioned something that's kind of in some ways dethrone the Oscars at its own party in a way.
还有很多大电影明星，人们，我们所有人都知道的名字，当然我们三个去过很多次并享受过。它已经成为了它自己的东西，如果你仔细想想，这真是太神奇了。它在某种程度上在自己的派对上让奥斯卡退位了。这，你知道，你谈到了，你提到了有趣的事情，
Which, you know, you spoke some, you mentioned something that's interesting, the idea that America's true expert is its culture and its obsession with celebrity peaked, you know, it reached the peak, a fever pitch, if you will, in the 90s, as my father calls it, celebrity, in a way that I think that he does that
即美国真正的专家是其文化，以及对名人的痴迷达到了顶峰，你知道，它达到了顶峰，狂热，如果你愿意的话，在90年代，正如我父亲所称的那样，名人，以一种我认为他这样做的方式，
just to demean the term itself. And he will claim that that's the actual way that you should pronounce it. But he also says to Motto, here's my point. It occurs to me, and I've long thought this, if we were really smart about wanting to sort of peddle influence around the world in a way that America seems hell bent on doing,
只是为了贬低这个词本身。他会声称那是你应该发音的实际方式。但他还说，这是我的观点。我突然想到，我长期以来一直这样认为，如果我们真的聪明地想在世界各地兜售影响力，以美国似乎铁了心要去做的方式，
we would, and this would never go down with the people who, you know, with the military industrial complex, which is, you know, a trillion dollars, I think, as of yesterday, a trillion dollar a year business. What we could do and much more efficiently is, if we wanted to influence a certain country and its people, etc., all we need to do, at the time I used to say drop our DVDs of our TV shows and dumb them down as much as we're dumbed down.
我们会，这永远不会被那些，你知道，与军工复合体（截至昨天，我想是万亿美元，一年一万亿美元的生意）有关的人接受。我们可以做且更有效率的是，如果我们想影响某个国家及其人民等，我们所要做的，当时我常说，就是投放我们的电视节目DVD，并把它们弄得像我们一样笨。
If we could pump in Netflix and Amazon Prime and Macs to all these countries for free, they would immediately lay down their weapons because they'd become just as dumb as we are. Or as smart. Sorry, or as smart, thank you for allowing me. But do you know what I mean? I mean, that would seem to me to be the answer to all of it. Well, it's an element of soft power and we've sort of given up all our soft power
如果我们能免费向所有这些国家注入Netflix、亚马逊Prime和Max，他们会立即放下武器，因为他们会变得和我们一样笨。或者一样聪明。抱歉，或者一样聪明，谢谢你允许我。但你知道我的意思吗？我的意思是，那对我来说似乎是所有问题的答案。好吧，这是软实力的一种元素，我们在过去三个月里放弃了我们所有的软实力。
in the last three months. We should be pumping them with TikTok and YouTube and paying for it and star linking it into their country. And believe me, they'll be like, hey, listen, we were gonna go and fight on the front line and like, hang on a second, I just gotta watch this thing about a cat teaching itself to read.
我们应该用TikTok和YouTube给他们注入，并为此付费，通过星链进入他们的国家。相信我，他们会说，嘿，听着，我们本来打算去前线战斗，等等，我得看这个关于猫自学阅读的东西。
Do you know what I mean? Yeah, I mean, we do do that in a certain way. I mean, America, if you look at the way most kids dress anywhere in the world, they're wearing, you know, American style trainers, blue jeans, T-shirts with something written on them and plaid. Everybody looks like they're in a writing room, no matter what country you're in. You know?
你知道我的意思吗？是啊，我的意思是，我们确实以某种方式做到了。我的意思是，美国，如果你看看世界上大多数孩子穿衣服的方式，他们穿着，你知道，美式运动鞋、蓝色牛仔裤、写着东西的T恤和格子衬衫。每个人看起来都像在编剧室里，无论你在哪个国家。你知道吗？
It's so true. And you see rally, you see these people protesting and they have effigies of the president and whatever and they're wearing baseball caps backwards and they're wearing a guest jeans switcher and you're like, wait a second. And the irony is completely lost on everybody. That's our gift to the world.
太真实了。你看到人们抗议，他们有总统的肖像等等，他们戴着反向棒球帽，穿着盖斯牛仔裤，你会想，等一下。而讽刺的是每个人都完全忽略了这一点。那是我们给世界的礼物。
Well, and sort of expanding on that, Graydon, do you have an opinion about what sort of the current prognosis is for America being able to bear and withstand what some people are saying, kind of the hit that the American brand is taking across the world? Like, do you think after everything settles, at whatever point that is, that America will still hold a respectable place in the world? I think it'll all depend on the next sort of three or four years.
好吧，延伸一下，格雷登，你对美国能够承受和抵御一些人所说的美国品牌在世界范围内受到的打击有什么看法？比如，你认为在一切尘埃落定后，无论那是什么时候，美国在世界上仍然会占据一个受人尊敬的位置吗？我认为这完全取决于接下来的三四年。
I think it's really tarnished. And I, you know, we're leaving for Europe on next weekend and for a spell. And we have these little pins made up. We made up for our airmail shop over in Hudson Street here. And it just says- It's a great shop, by the way. I was there two weeks ago.
我认为它真的被玷污了。而且，你知道，我们下周末要去欧洲待一段时间。我们制作了这些小徽章。我们为我们在哈德逊街的《航空邮件》商店制作的。上面写着——顺便说一句，那是一家很棒的商店。我两周前去过那里。
It's fantastic. And the little pins, they just say, I didn't vote for them. And so when you're at a market in France or in a pub in England, people, it's just, because it'll be difficult. It was difficult during the years of George Bush, George W. Bush as well.
太棒了。那些小徽章，上面只写着：我没投他们的票。所以当你在法国的市场或英国的酒吧时，人们，这只是，因为这会很困难。在乔治·布什、乔治·W·布什执政期间也很困难。
And it may take a generation for the so-called American brand to correct. Great, and do you want me to send you over a couple of these Canada patches? Love them. From your back. Love them. They are useful to have.
可能需要一代人的时间才能让所谓的美国品牌得到纠正。格雷登，你想让我给你寄几张加拿大补丁吗？喜欢它们。从你的背后。喜欢它们。它们很有用。
They are really useful. All of a sudden, everybody who travels is a Canadian. You have Americans practicing their Canadian patois. Because Canadians end every sentence with a question mark. Like an American will say, I'm going to the store. A Canadian will say, I'm going to the store. As if like, can I get you something sort of thing. Right.
它们真的很有用。突然间，每个旅行的人都是加拿大人。你有美国人在练习他们的加拿大口音。因为加拿大人在每个句子结尾都用问号。就像美国人会说，我要去商店。加拿大人会说，我要去商店？好像是，我能为你带点什么之类的。没错。
Yeah, that's nice. Wait, great, as far as journalism goes and kind of to what Jason was saying about Scott Galloway, you know Scott Galloway? Oh yeah. Yeah, we got to have him on the show. He's brilliant. I know.
是啊，那很好。等等，格雷登，就新闻业而言，以及杰森关于斯科特·加洛韦所说的，你知道斯科特·加洛韦吗？哦，是的。是啊，我们得请他上节目。他很聪明。我知道。
Yeah, he's great, very, very smart man. And I saw this clip either again on TikTok or Instagram or something, and he said- We can take over your house in two minutes. Yeah. You wouldn't get off the couch. Yeah, exactly. He said nobody wants to read anymore.
是啊，他很棒，非常非常聪明的人。我再次在TikTok或Instagram上看到了这个片段，他说——我们可以在两分钟内接管你的房子。是啊。你不会离开沙发的。是啊，没错。他说没人想再读书了。
That's not true. Period. And he goes, everybody's getting their information from obviously TikTok or Instagram because nobody wants to sit down and read articles or magazines or books or anything. And so, and that said, people know that people of influence know that. So they'll just speak to these kids or these people
那不是真的。句号。他说，每个人都在从TikTok或Instagram获取信息，因为没人想坐下来阅读文章、杂志或书之类的东西。所以，话虽如此，有影响力的人知道这一点。所以他们只会对这些孩子或这些人说话，
about what it is they should know. And that's how they get their information out. Okay, well, a counter-argument to that would be that the fact is the New York Times has never been more successful. It's never been larger. If you look at a magazine like, say, The Atlantic, The Atlantic is exponentially larger
关于他们应该知道什么。这就是他们发布信息的方式。好吧，反驳的论点是，事实是《纽约时报》从未如此成功。它从未如此庞大。如果你看看像《大西洋月刊》这样的杂志，《大西洋月刊》比15年前呈指数级增长，
and more influential than it was say 15 years ago. But that's a certain demographic, I think. It is a certain demographic, but at the same time most people watch TV with the, even with most people watch TV with the, the Chiron, you know, the whatever it is. Yeah, yeah, with the professional show people call that. Subtitles.
而且更有影响力。但那是一个特定的人口统计，我想。它确实是一个特定的人口统计，但与此同时，大多数人看电视时，即使大多数人看电视时，字幕，你知道，无论那是什么。是啊，是啊，专业人士称之为。字幕。
Subtitles. And so young people, I think it's harder and harder, and I have a feeling that most of us, if we were growing up with TikTok, and that we would read less than, and but it also, you know, most, I have five kids, and I know that some of them didn't read that much when they were in their teens,
字幕。所以年轻人，我认为越来越难，我有一种感觉，我们大多数人，如果我们是在TikTok中长大的，我们会读得更少，但它也，你知道，大多数，我有五个孩子，我知道他们十几岁时读得不多，
but they're all huge readers now. They're all writers, and so they're all huge readers. You just have to wait a bit and it'll come around. Yeah, yeah, that's true. Yeah, Sean and Jason, what are you guys waiting for? Yeah. I always say to these guys, but anyways, they're unlucky.
但他们现在都是大读者。他们都是作家，所以他们都是大读者。你只需要等一会儿，它就会好起来的。是啊，是啊，那是真的。是啊，肖恩和杰森，你们在等什么？是啊。我总是对这些人说，但无论如何，他们很不幸。
I've got a boring story I won't bore you with about why I'm not a great reader, but I will tell you that- Does it have to do with you don't know how to read? Is that the headline? It's top to bottom, left to right. Right? There's now you can...
我有一个很无聊的故事，关于为什么我不擅长阅读，我就不拿这个来烦你了，但我可以告诉你——这和你不知道怎么阅读有关吗？这是标题吗？是从上到下，从左到右，对吧？现在你可以……
Every article online is now you can listen to it. Right, that's what I'm saying. And it is something that's helped both of my girls where they have these large reading assignments for school and now all those books are audio books as well. And so one of the teachers suggested, and I thought it was a great idea, get them the audio book so they can listen to it
现在网上的每一篇文章你都可以听了。对，我说的就是这个。这对我两个女儿都有帮助，她们在学校有大量的阅读作业，现在所有这些书也都有有声读物了。所以其中一位老师建议——我觉得这是个好主意——给她们买有声读物，这样她们就可以在阅读时听。
as they read it. I agree. And that's helpful and you get some momentum going, you get engaged in the story, and now maybe you don't need that crutch for chapters five through 10. You can actually just read the book. And so I do, that's helpful.
我同意。这很有帮助，你可以产生一些动力，投入到故事中，也许在读第五到第十章时就不需要那个拐杖了。你实际上可以直接阅读这本书。所以我认为这很有帮助。
That's somewhat of a phenomenon where, like you say, the New York Times grade, I would imagine their online business is larger than their print business. I think it's 9 tenths of it, but still they're reading it online. But they're still reading it. I will say that though,
这在某种程度上是一种现象，就像你说的，纽约时报的等级，我想象他们的在线业务比印刷业务要大。我认为占了十分之九，但他们仍然是在线阅读。但他们确实还在阅读。不过我得说，
and I do bang this drum quite often, but there is a certain reading it, for me reading at the end of the day, I find to be such an extreme luxury. And it's very calming because we do live in a digital world. I'm looking at my screen all day, I'm looking at my computer, at my thing, whatever.
我经常敲响这个警钟，但对我来说，在一天结束时阅读确实是一种极大的奢侈。这非常令人平静，因为我们确实生活在一个数字世界里。我整天盯着屏幕，看着我的电脑，看着我的东西，等等。
And to have that moment for 45 minutes every night to read, I do find that it is so calming in this sort of chaotic world in which we live, if nothing else, apart from the fact that it's interesting and you can beat all the other great things about reading. But in that way, and especially as we get older, I'm not speaking to you, Graydon, I'm speaking to Sean and Jason. Because I am older, yeah. You need to calm down. You need to calm down, both of you. Especially as we get older.
每天晚上有45分钟的时间来阅读，我发现这在我们生活的这个混乱世界里非常令人平静，即使别的不说，撇开阅读本身很有趣以及所有其他优点不谈。但在这一点上，尤其是随着我们年龄的增长——我不是在对你说，Graydon，我是在对Sean和Jason说。因为我确实老了，是的。你们需要冷静下来。你们两个都需要冷静下来。尤其是随着我们年龄的增长。
You need to calm down. I still read a lot online and stuff. What do you attribute, Graydon, not the demise, but the way that magazines have not, you say like the New York Times for example, never been more profitable, yet it is now intense online now. Why did the same not translate for the periodicals? I mean, the financial crash of 2008 was an issue because the first thing that people could take off their balance,
你们需要冷静下来。我仍然在网上读很多东西。Graydon，你认为是什么原因导致了杂志的——不是消亡，而是杂志没有像你说的《纽约时报》那样，从未如此盈利，但现在却在网上如此激烈。为什么期刊没有发生同样的情况？我的意思是，2008年的金融危机是一个问题，因为人们首先能从资产负债表中剔除的，
off their accounts were advertising because then you don't have to fire anybody. So the advertising started disappearing. The new, and then even in New York City, there used to be a newsstand at every major intersection, sometimes one across the street from each other. There was a newsstand in every office building. Now, when you see a newsstand on the street,
从他们的账户中剔除的就是广告，因为这样你就不必解雇任何人了。所以广告开始消失。新的，甚至在纽约市，每个主要路口曾经都有一个报刊亭，有时甚至在街道对面各有一个。每栋办公楼里都有一个报刊亭。现在，当你看到街上的报刊亭时，
it's often a movie set thing because they're gone. And in office buildings, wherever there was a newsstand, it's usually, they're selling gum and flip-flops and lotto tickets. So just the fact that you used to be able to see magazines everywhere you went. You know, in Los Angeles, those things in Hollywood,
它通常是电影布景，因为它们已经消失了。在办公楼里，曾经有报刊亭的地方，通常现在卖的是口香糖、人字拖和彩票。所以，仅仅是你曾经去过的任何地方都能看到杂志这一事实。你知道，在洛杉矶，好莱坞的那些东西，
but the long walls of magazines. I love those. Anyway, that's sort of, they're gone. And I think a lot of magazines companies were late to transfer their way, a magazine looks, to an electronic version. And the thing about Air Mail is Air Mail was put together by magazine people and we didn't have to work with a legacy brand and then transfer it to the internet And the thing about Airmail is Airmail was put together
还有那些长长的杂志墙。我喜欢那些。总之，它们消失了。我认为很多杂志公司在将杂志外观转换为电子版本方面行动迟缓。关于Air Mail，Air Mail是由杂志从业者创办的，我们不必处理遗留品牌，然后再将其转移到互联网上。关于Air Mail，Air Mail是由
by magazine people and we didn't have to work I can read them all on my iPad. But before you go too far past Airmail, I just love what you, it's so, and this is probably not the right term, but there's nothing like, here's, it's basically like looking at the table of contents page. Are you talking about the subscription to Vanity Fair? Or no, to Air Mail?
杂志从业者创办的，我们不必处理……我可以在iPad上阅读它们。但在你谈论Air Mail太远之前，我真的很喜欢你所做的，这太……这可能不是正确的术语，但没有什么比这更好的了，这基本上就像看着目录页。你在说《名利场》的订阅吗？还是不，是Air Mail？
No, it's switching to Graydon's new thing, is this thing called Air Mail. So you get this email and here's like five stories that you can click on, that then if you decide to click, then it expands into the story. So there's just like, you don't have to buy a whole magazine or you don't have to go to a magazine's website or anything and like have to like deal with all the advertising
不，是转向Graydon的新事物，这个叫Air Mail的东西。所以你会收到这封电子邮件，这里有五篇你可以点击的故事，如果你决定点击，它就会展开成完整的故事。所以你不需要买整本杂志，也不需要去杂志的网站，或者处理所有的广告，
and the big pictures and all that. It's just, here's some ideas, some stories, if it's interesting to you, click on it. If not, go to the next email. Like so it's not in your face, the medicine goes down easy and they happen to be incredible stories. So I don't know, I just think you tacked to a format that speaks to the current reader's appetite,
还有大图片之类的。它只是，这里有一些想法，一些故事，如果你感兴趣，就点击它。如果不感兴趣，就看下一封邮件。所以它不会强加于人，药很容易咽下去，而且它们恰好是令人难以置信的故事。所以我不知道，我只是觉得你采用了一种符合当前读者胃口的格式，
as far as the attention they have to get. And there's a tonal shift too, right, JB? I mean, there's a tonal shift in it from Vanity Fair to Air Mail that's, you know. Yeah, there's no selling element to it that I think people have grown sort of an allergy to. And you're just, you're very current on that, which is not surprising coming from somebody like you.
就他们所能投入的注意力而言。而且语调也有所转变，对吧，JB？我的意思是，从《名利场》到Air Mail的语调确实发生了转变，你知道的。是的，它没有那种我认为人们已经产生某种过敏的销售元素。而且你在这方面非常前卫，这对于像你这样的人来说并不令人惊讶。
Well, we wanted to look beautiful because I think design means everything these days. And look at the amount of work that goes into an iPhone, say. So, you know, as I said, I'd written thank you notes to all my advertisers at Vanity Fair, and so I wanted those advertisers in Air Mail. I didn't want advertising for, I don't know, foot fungus or, you know, Geico insurance ads.
嗯，我们希望它看起来很漂亮，因为我认为设计在当今意味着一切。看看iPhone投入的工作量，比如说。所以，正如我所说，我给《名利场》的所有广告商写过感谢信，所以我希望那些广告商出现在Air Mail中。我不想要那种，我不知道，脚气药或者，你知道，Geico保险广告。
I wanted, you know, much better to have Hermes and Dior around Florida. So, all the advertisers, once I got Hermes, all the other advertisers felt safe coming in, but it's put up by people from Time Magazine, when I worked there, Spy Magazine, and Vanity Fair. That's the core group, and then there's about
我想要，你知道，最好有爱马仕和迪奥。所以，一旦我拉到了爱马仕，所有其他广告商都觉得进来很安全，但它是《时代》杂志的人创办的，我曾在那里工作过，《Spy》杂志，还有《名利场》。这是核心团队，然后大约有
eight young people who are in their mid-20s, and they form the core in the future. Yeah. Well, we'd be remiss if we didn't mention our mutual friend, the great Linda Wells, who are in their mid-20s, and they form the core in the future. Well, we'd be remiss if we didn't mention our mutual friend, the great Linda Wells, whom I adore. Me too. Yeah, whom I absolutely adore and have known for many years,
八个20多岁的年轻人，他们构成了未来的核心。是的。嗯，如果我们不提我们的共同朋友，伟大的Linda Wells，那将是我们的失职，他们20多岁，构成了未来的核心。嗯，如果我们不提我们的共同朋友，伟大的Linda Wells，那将是我们的失职，我崇拜她。我也是。是的，我绝对崇拜她，并且认识很多年了，
and she's a big part of Air Mail. I'm not telling you, I'm telling our listener, our single listener. But I will say that when you were at Vanity Fair, there was a real balance between covering high society profiles, if you will, celebrity and investigative journalism. I remember there's a great article that I've referenced many times and had people read, which was about
她是Air Mail的重要组成部分。我不是在告诉你，我是在告诉我们的听众，我们唯一的听众。但我得说，当你在《名利场》时，在报道上流社会人物、名人调查新闻之间有一种真正的平衡。我记得有一篇很棒的文章，我引用过很多次，也让人们读过，那是关于
the Salton of Brunei's brother. Love that story. That story is an incredible story, still holds up. It's incredible, it's hilarious, and it's right on point, and it's scathing and yet very fair. So you do that at Vanity Fair. And then now that you're at Air Mail, how would you define, what is your relationship,
文莱苏丹的弟弟。喜欢那个故事。那个故事是一个令人难以置信的故事，至今仍然站得住脚。它令人难以置信，非常滑稽，而且切中要害，既尖刻又非常公平。所以你在《名利场》做到了这一点。现在你在Air Mail，你会如何定义，你与名人文化的关系是什么，
well, I was gonna say what's your relationship with celebrity culture. Before I say that, what was, because you were at the forefront of defining celebrity and covering celebrity culture back at Vanity Fair, and you still are at Air Mail in a way, when you were in that position, what kind of incoming calls did you get from people,
嗯，我本来想问你与名人文化的关系是什么。在我说那个之前，因为你在《名利场》时处于定义名人并报道名人文化的最前沿，而且在某种程度上你现在在Air Mail仍然如此，当你处于那个位置时，你从人们那里收到了什么样的来电，
from publicists and celebrities themselves who wanted you to either amend something that you wrote about them, and I know you already mentioned this about Mr. Tisch, but what celebrities did you get? Did you ever get a call from that Donald Trump pseudonym? John Barron. John Barron.
来自公关人员和名人本身，他们希望你修改你写关于他们的东西，我知道你已经提到了关于Tisch先生的事，但你收到了哪些名人的电话？你有没有收到过那个唐纳德·特朗普化名的电话？John Barron。John Barron。
No, but I would get calls from Trump, and once they invented Twitter, he went to town on me. He would call me a floppy, I was a loser. The Waverly Inn was a failing restaurant. The Oscar party wasn't hot. The magazine was terrible. But I would take any phone call. But mostly, doing the covers was actually
没有，但我会接到特朗普的电话，一旦他们发明了Twitter，他就开始针对我了。他会叫我软弱，我是个失败者。Waverly Inn是一家失败的餐厅。奥斯卡派对一点也不火。杂志太糟糕了。但我会接任何电话。但主要是，做封面实际上是
the least favorite part of the job. But the fact is, movie, you know, show people like you are more attractive than the rest of us. So having a very attractive person on the cover who happened to be talented was a great way of getting the attention of the reader so that they'd pick it up and they wouldn't be embarrassed putting it on their coffee table.
工作中我最不喜欢的部分。但事实是，电影，你知道，像你们这样的人比我们其他人更有吸引力。所以封面上有一个非常有吸引力且恰好有才华的人，是吸引读者注意力的好方法，这样他们就会拿起它，而且把它放在咖啡桌上也不会感到尴尬。
But once you got that, that was sort of like the wrapping and then the magazine itself was sort of the gift in the box. But most of the calls, and we did get a lot of complaints, but they were routed through the office of the person who, of the people who booked the covers. So I got, I would get occasional complaints. Most of the complaints often would come from staff members.
但一旦你得到了那个，那就像是包装，而杂志本身就是盒子里的礼物。但大多数电话，我们确实收到了很多投诉，但它们是通过预订封面的人的办公室转达的。所以我偶尔会收到投诉。大多数投诉通常来自员工。
And I remember Christopher Hitchens did a pretty rough story on Mother Teresa. And he accused her of like cozying up to dictators and that sort of thing from money. It came out of the blue and it was wild. And Rinaldo Herrera, who's the husband of Carolina Herrera who was on the staff, and he came, he was sta. And, Rinaldo Herrera, who's the husband of Carolina Herrera, who was on the staff, and he came, he was staunch Catholic, and he came into the office,
我记得Christopher Hitchens写了一篇关于特蕾莎修女的相当粗糙的文章。他指责她为了钱而讨好独裁者之类的事情。这突如其来，非常疯狂。Rinaldo Herrera，他是Carolina Herrera的丈夫，他在员工名单里，他来了，他是……Rinaldo Herrera，他是Carolina Herrera的丈夫，他在员工名单里，他来了，他是坚定的天主教徒，他走进办公室，
stormed into the office, and said, Graden, you've gone too far this time. What do you mean? He said, Mother Tracy, I'm canceling my subscription. I said, you can't cancel your subscription. You get it for free. And so, but at Spy Magazine, once we did a story on the 10 most litigious New Yorkers,
冲进办公室说，Graden，你这次太过分了。你什么意思？他说，特蕾莎修女，我要取消我的订阅。我说，你不能取消你的订阅。你是免费得到的。所以，但在《Spy》杂志，有一次我们做了一个关于纽约十大诉讼狂人的故事，
and Gore Vidal was on that list, and we were listening to the phone book, and he called me up and he said, I really object to this, I'd never met him before, I really object to this, and if you don't take my name, if you don't correct that, I'll sue you." And I said, wait a minute, if we don't correct that you're one of the most litigious New Yorkers,
Gore Vidal在那个名单上，我们正在听电话簿，他打电话给我说，我真的反对这个，我以前从未见过他，我真的反对这个，如果你不把我的名字拿掉，如果你不纠正那个，我就起诉你。我说，等一下，如果我们不纠正你是纽约最爱打官司的人之一，
you're going to sue us. He said, yes. And I said, don't you get the irony in his own thing that he just hung up. That's great. That's so good. We'll be right back. And back to the show. Your new book, Graydon, is When the Going Was Good,
你就要起诉我们。他说，是的。我说，你没明白你自己说的话里的讽刺意味吗？他就挂断了。太棒了。太好了。我们马上回来。回到节目。Graydon，你的新书是《When the Going Was Good》，
which is out now. And talk a little bit about that. First of all, what a great title. You're clearly not talking about yourself. Because things continue to have a nice arc. You're talking about a cultural shift, yeah. Is that the sort of, talk a little bit about the book. No, I think that the, you know, if you look back
现在已经出版了。谈谈那本书吧。首先，多么棒的标题。你显然不是在谈论你自己。因为事情继续有一个很好的弧线。你是在谈论一种文化转变，是的。是那种……谈谈那本书吧。不，我认为，你知道，如果你回顾
and the 80s, the 90s and the aughts, with the, I mean, if you look back in the 80s, the 90s, and the aughts, with the, I mean, the 80s and 90s in particular, it was a great time in America. It was very aspirational. The middle class was doing well. We still had two World Trade Center towers. You could get on an airplane without stripping down. There was no cell phones or social media.
80年代、90年代和00年代，我的意思是，如果你回顾80年代、90年代和00年代，我的意思是，特别是80年代和90年代，那是美国的一段美好时光。它非常有抱负。中产阶级过得很好。我们还有两座世界贸易中心大厦。你可以不脱衣服就上飞机。没有手机或社交媒体。
And it was a, it was just a much more natural, organic time. When my wife and I happened to love watching Frasier before we go to bed, because they're like perfectly written plays, and nobody has a cell phone, and there's just something, you know, I mean the same thing with Will and Grace, or Friends, or I'm trying to think what else, Seinfeld say.
那是一个更自然、更有机的时代。我和我妻子碰巧喜欢在睡觉前看《欢乐一家亲》，因为它们就像写得完美的剧本，没有人有手机，而且有一些，你知道，我的意思是《威尔和格蕾丝》或者《老友记》也是一样，或者我在想还有什么，比如《宋飞正传》。
And it was just a great time. And so the 80s, 90s and aughts, with the exception of, you know, obviously 9-11 and everything that came after that, were a great time for television, a great time for movies. And I think television has overtaken movies now too, in terms of driving the culture.
那是一段美好的时光。所以80年代、90年代和00年代，除了，你知道，显然是9-11以及之后发生的一切，是电视的美好时光，电影的美好时光。而且我认为电视现在也已经超越了电影，在推动文化方面。
Magazines do not drive the culture like they used to. It's obviously the things like Instagram and television in a big way. So do you think we'll ever get back to what you're describing? No. No. Ever, or a version of it?
杂志不像过去那样推动文化了。显然是像Instagram和电视这样的大型事物。所以你认为我们还能回到你所描述的那种状态吗？不。不。曾经，或者它的一个版本？
A version of it, perhaps. I think young people will come to love magazines the way they love vinyl. Yeah, I was gonna say. But there'll be specialty magazines. There won't be a million circulation and they will be largely visual. Like, you know, you go to like Casa magazines
也许是一个版本。我认为年轻人会像喜欢黑胶唱片一样喜欢杂志。是的，我正想说。但那将是专业杂志。不会有百万的发行量，而且它们将主要是视觉化的。就像，你知道，你去像第八大道的Casa杂志店
on Eighth Avenue over here. Yeah. And there's a ton of these big, expensive, $20 perfect bound, thick paper magazines. And they get scooped up by young people, not by people over 30. There's one of those great, there are about four every corner
这里。是的。那里有成吨的这种大型、昂贵、20美元的完美装订、厚纸杂志。它们被年轻人抢购一空，而不是30岁以上的人。有那些很棒的，每个角落大约有四个
from West Broadway to Sixth Avenue. There are three or four bodegas on every corner. There's that one at the corner of Sullivan and Prince that still has a really robust magazine section. You know that, you know what I'm talking about? I know exactly what I'm talking about? I know exactly what you're talking about. I've been listening, I've been living half a block from it
从西百老汇到第六大道。每个角落都有三四家便利店。Sullivan和Prince街角的那一家仍然有一个非常强大的杂志区。你知道那个，你知道我在说什么吗？我知道我在说什么吗？我知道你在说什么。我已经在那里住了半个街区
for the last sort of six months and it's been phenomenal and I've gone in there, I found myself going in there from time to time and perusing magazines again and I feel like I'm stepping back in time. Yeah, I think it'll come back, I think. What do you think is the, you know, we talk often about, and we've referenced it here today, the effect of social media has had on our culture, which to me, in large part,
在过去的六个月里，这太棒了，我时不时地进去，发现自己又在里面浏览杂志，感觉就像回到了过去。是的，我想它会回来的，我想。你认为，你知道，我们经常谈论，今天我们也提到了，社交媒体对我们文化的影响，对我来说，在很大程度上，
I think has been quite a negative effect. What do you think the future is for things like social media in going forward? Do you think there will be a whiplash or a backlash rather? I was gonna say, I think I'm hoping that because- I wasn't asking you. I mean- No, no, but I want to say,
我认为这是一种相当负面的影响。你认为社交媒体之类的东西未来会怎样？你认为会有反弹吗？我正想说，我想我希望因为……我不是在问你。我的意思是……不，不，但我想要说，
no, it's funny because you brought up social media because I think we've so overshared our lives in such a massive way and billions of people, now we know everything about everybody always, that I think if I'm guessing correctly, we will go the opposite way in five, 10, 20 years, whatever it is, I don't know, where people will be like,
不，这很有趣，因为你提到了社交媒体，因为我认为我们已经以如此巨大的方式过度分享了我们的生活，数十亿人，现在我们总是知道关于每个人的所有事情，我想如果我猜得对，我们会在5年、10年、20年内走向相反的方向，无论是什么，我不知道，人们会像，
wait, we've all overshared, I'm going to get off it. I think it's cooler to hang out without it. I think it was a long way away, but I think that's what's going to happen. Greta, what do you think? 100%. I think, yeah, I totally out without it. I think it was a long way away, but I think that's what's gonna happen. Greta, what do you think? 100%, I think, yeah, I totally agree with Sean that it is, again, it's a correction. And so the correction, now you share everything,
等等，我们都过度分享了，我要退出它。我认为没有它去闲逛更酷。我认为这还有很长的路要走，但我认为这就是会发生的事情。Graydon，你怎么看？100%。我想，是的，我完全同意Sean的观点，这又是一次修正。所以修正，现在你分享一切，
pictures of your children, picture of your children's birthday, them having cake on their nose and all the rest of it. I have five kids, none of them have a social media presence and no tattoos either. So that's a major accomplishment. But I don't have a social media presence and no tattoos either. So that's a major accomplishment. But I don't have any social media presence and I think, and I know this sounds strange
你孩子的照片，你孩子生日的照片，他们鼻子上沾着蛋糕等等。我有五个孩子，他们都没有社交媒体账号，也没有纹身。所以这是一个重大的成就。但我没有社交媒体账号，也没有纹身。所以这是一个重大的成就。但我没有任何社交媒体账号，而且我认为，我知道这听起来很奇怪
for somebody who's just written a memoir, but I'm a very private person. And I think a private life will have greater currency in maybe three to five years than it does now and it'll be much cooler for young people than having social media presence. A greater currency, and it gives you more cache. Much more cache, there's a mystery.
对于一个刚刚写了回忆录的人来说，但我是一个非常注重隐私的人。而且我认为私生活在三到五年内会比现在更有价值，对年轻人来说，这会比拥有社交媒体账号酷得多。更有价值，它给你更多的声望。多得多的声望，有一种神秘感。
Well, it's so great, and kind of on this, this sort of this cultural transition period we find ourselves in, hopefully, and you being the head of a major media effort, talk to us about your process with you and your team when you decide what stories it is you're going to go forward with there on Airmail. Is there any agenda such a pejorative? But do you consider the effect and the move
嗯，这太棒了，关于这个，我们发现自己所处的这种文化转型期，希望如此，而你作为一家大型媒体机构的负责人，跟我们谈谈你和你的团队在决定Air Mail上要推进哪些故事时的流程。有什么议程吗？这太贬义了。但你是否考虑过这种影响和举动
that you guys can make for people, as you try to encourage them towards a better, healthier, you know, cultural position? Or is it just stories of interest to you guys personally? I mean, I put the next issue together on a Sunday morning, and it's my favorite process of the week. personally? I mean I put the the next issue together on a Sunday morning and it's my favorite process of the week but by and large we look for stories that have not appeared in the American papers. It's sort of intended as the
你们可以为人们做出的改变，当你试图鼓励他们走向一个更好、更健康的文化立场时？还是仅仅是你们个人感兴趣的故事？我的意思是，我在周日早上整理下一期，这是我一周中最喜欢的流程。个人而言？我的意思是，我在周日早上整理下一期，这是我一周中最喜欢的流程，但总的来说，我们寻找那些没有出现在美国报纸上的故事。它旨在作为
weekend edition of a non-existent international newspaper like the old International Herald Tribune. And the fact is there's so much to celebrate about life. It's not all about Donald Trump that we have. It's hard to avoid Donald Trump. I mean, it's certainly worth the effort to avoid him, but it's almost impossible. And so he winds up in there.
一份不存在的国际报纸的周末版，就像老《国际先驱论坛报》。事实上，生活中有很多值得庆祝的事情。我们拥有的并不全是关于唐纳德·特朗普。很难避开唐纳德·特朗普。我的意思是，避开他确实值得努力，但几乎是不可能的。所以他最终还是会出现在里面。
But it was designed as a, we started it during the first Trump administration, and I was living in France, and it was designed as a, sort of not the same, like every single newsletter you get in America is, you know, it's all basically Boston to Washington to sell a corridor news and we have very little of that. There's enough of that to go around.
但它被设计成一个，我们在特朗普第一届政府期间创办了它，当时我住在法国，它被设计成一个，某种程度上不是一样的，就像你在美国收到的每一份时事通讯，你知道，基本上都是波士顿到华盛顿的走廊新闻，而我们几乎没有那种东西。那种东西已经够多了。
So ours is very international. Stories have to be just interesting and things that reflect changes in the culture, hopefully for the better, not always. And just sort of spirited writing that could be funny, but informative, and some new fresh voices. And it's just something that you can wake up Saturday morning and read it
所以我们的是非常国际化的。故事必须是有趣的，并且是反映文化变化的事物，希望是向好的方向，并不总是这样。而且只是一些充满活力的写作，可能很有趣，但信息量大，还有一些新的新鲜声音。这只是你可以周六早上醒来阅读的东西
without completely hanging your head in despair over the news. I took the New York Times alerts off my phone. Yeah, every 45 seconds is like the end of the world. And it was like, I know. Same here. And I've been doing my best to try to avoid it. Totally, same.
而不会因为新闻而完全陷入绝望。我把手机上的《纽约时报》提醒关掉了。是的，每45秒就像世界末日一样。就像，我知道。我也是。我一直在尽我所能去避免它。完全一样。
Do you, you've been a, for lack of a better word, a tastemaker for decades. It's just simply true. What cultural trends, are there any that you now that you miss most or, and what do you think, what cultural trends do you think are wildly overrated now? Well, the social media, as I think Sean points out,
你，你一直是一个，用一个更好的词来说，几十年的潮流引领者。这简直是真的。有什么文化趋势，有什么你现在最怀念的，或者，你认为现在哪些文化趋势被严重高估了？嗯，社交媒体，正如我认为Sean指出的那样，
that it will have a swing back because the not sharing everything will be a value in both in your life and your personality and your interactions with others. I think kindness would make it be a wonderful addition back in the world, because I think the sort of wanton cruelty you see coming out of Washington is a,
它会有一个回摆，因为不分享一切在你的生活、个性和与他人的互动中都将是一种价值。我认为善良会成为世界上一个美妙的补充，因为我认为你在华盛顿看到的那种肆意的残忍，
it sort of reflects badly in us, even though most of us are not like that. And I don't think it's gonna get better soon, but I think it will get better. And- I think so too. He's a very strange man. I've known him for 40 years.
它在某种程度上反映了我们的糟糕，尽管我们大多数人不是那样。我不认为它很快会好转，但我认为它会好转。而且……我也这么认为。他是一个非常奇怪的人。我认识他40年了。
He's both loved me and hated me. Yeah. And he reads young, he reads like a young 78, whereas Biden read like an old 81. I know, you gotta give him that credit, it's hard not to. Graydon, at the great risk of offending you, okay? Oh, go ahead.
他既爱我也恨我。是的。而且他读起来像一个年轻的78岁，而拜登读起来像一个老81岁。我知道，你得给他那个赞誉，很难不给。Graydon，冒着冒犯你的巨大风险，好吗？哦，继续吧。
Uh-oh, oh boy, oh no, this is his favorite. Can you please walk me through the genesis of your incredible and impressive hair? Oh my God, we'll take a good look at it because it's disappearing as we speak. No, no, it's, no, no. What it is is it's one of my favorite things about you, always has been.
呃哦，哦男孩，哦不，这是他最喜欢的。你能带我了解一下你那令人难以置信且印象深刻的发型的起源吗？哦天哪，好好看看它吧，因为它正在消失。不，不，它，不，不。它是我最喜欢你的地方之一，一直都是。
To the extent you're comfortable, can you please walk us through how it started and what the process is to make, is there a pick involved? Yeah, because put a baton in your hand and you can conduct the New York Phil. I just fucking love it so much. No, I had this hair, it's the same hair I have
在你感到舒适的范围内，你能带我们了解一下它是怎么开始的，以及制作它的过程是什么吗，有用到拨片吗？是的，因为把指挥棒放在你手里，你就可以指挥纽约爱乐乐团了。我他妈太喜欢它了。不，我有这个头发，它和我30岁时书封面上的一模一样。
on the cover of my book when I was 30. And it's sort of, you know, in the old days, when I didn't have much money, you'd get it all cut off and you'd wait three months and it would grow back. Now I get it cut every month or so, and it's just, but it's gone gray, and if I come out in Los Angeles and I go and there's a lot of people my age in the room,
它在某种程度上，你知道，在过去，当我没有多少钱的时候，你会把它全部剪掉，然后等三个月它就会长回来。现在我每个月左右剪一次，它只是，但它已经变灰了，如果我出现在洛杉矶，房间里有很多我这个年纪的人，
I'm the only man with gray hair, which I find really amazing. How's that possible? It's pretty cool, it has something to do with the water out here, I think. The styling of it is just, I just love it, because it's just a perfect juxtaposition between this incredible place of,
我是唯一一个有灰头发的男人，我觉得这真的很神奇。这怎么可能？这很酷，我想这和这里的水有关。它的造型只是，我只是喜欢它，因为它是一个完美的并置，介于这个令人难以置信的地位，
oh, influence and success and sophistication that you hold and it's sort of offset, I mean, it's like Einstein, you know, like Einstein was like the greatest brain ever, yet he counterbalanced it with his. Well, Pete Davidson once said, Pete Davidson told a friend of my daughter, he said, your dad, he looks like, and with that hair, he looks like he should be on Money.
哦，你所拥有的影响力和成功与成熟，它在某种程度上被抵消了，我的意思是，就像爱因斯坦，你知道，就像爱因斯坦是史上最伟大的大脑，但他用他的头发平衡了它。嗯，Pete Davidson曾经说过，Pete Davidson告诉过我女儿的一个朋友，他说，你爸爸，他看起来像，有了那个头发，他看起来应该出现在钱上。
Which I'm not gonna compliment anybody. It's sort of, you know, there's a confidence to it, which is intoxicating, I must admit. That's code for what a fool who would do that. No, not at all. No, no, no, no, no. Anybody who says how brave of you to wear that or something like that.
我不会恭维任何人。这在某种程度上，你知道，有一种自信，这是令人陶醉的，我必须承认。那是“多么愚蠢的人才会那样做”的代号。不，一点也不。不，不，不，不，不。任何说“你戴那个多勇敢”之类的话的人。
No, the opposite, the opposite. Well, great, now I'll leave you with this, and again, we pointed out all the great things, Spy Magazine, Vanity. Well, great, I'll leave you with this. And again, we pointed out all the great things, Spy Magazine, Vanity Fair, Air Mail, and now your book, When the Going Was Good. After decades. And don't forget the Waverly Inn. And the Waverly Inn.
不，相反，相反。嗯，Graydon，我留给你这个，再次，我们指出了所有伟大的事情，《Spy》杂志，《名利场》。嗯，Graydon，我留给你这个。再次，我们指出了所有伟大的事情，《Spy》杂志，《名利场》，Air Mail，现在是你的书，《When the Going Was Good》。几十年后。别忘了Waverly Inn。还有Waverly Inn。
And the Waverly Inn, which, sorry, the Waverly Inn, which is, I must admit, I haven't been to in a long time, but I love the Waverly Inn. And you can make a reservation through my email. Is that true? Yeah, do all the seating, do the seating every night. We'll treat you well. No, really?
还有Waverly Inn，我必须承认，我很久没去了，但我喜欢Waverly Inn。你可以通过我的电子邮件预订。是真的吗？是的，每天晚上做所有的座位安排。我们会好好招待你的。不，真的吗？
Fantastic, oh my God. Oh my God, what a dream. I'm coming back. I mean, don't put it on your website or anything like that. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Oh, believe me, I'm going to guard it with my life. I will tell you, and this probably won't be much of a compliment, because I'm probably one in a long line,
太棒了，哦天哪。哦天哪，真是个梦想。我要回来了。我的意思是，别把它放在你的网站上之类的。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。哦，相信我，我会用生命守护它。我会告诉你，这可能算不上什么恭维，因为我可能是在长队中的一个，
but I just finished doing this show and it's about an incredibly beautiful, hip restaurant on the Lower East Side. Called Black Rabbit. Shots of inside of Waverly End was up on our production designer's board. Oh, sweet. And we basically modeled modeled the aesthetic in there is just so incredibly beautiful.
但我刚刚做完这个节目，它是关于下东区一家令人难以置信的美丽、时髦的餐厅。叫Black Rabbit。Waverly Inn内部的照片就在我们制作设计师的板子上。哦，太好了。我们基本上模仿了那里的美学，它真是太美了。
And built down in Atlanta? No, actually we shot in New York. We built an entire restaurant at Steiner. Oh my God. You know what would be great to do? Let's do something like, now that we have Graded here, let's do a thing where we get Thoreau banned from the Waverly Inn forever. Like you know what I mean?
是在亚特兰大建的吗？不，实际上我们在纽约拍的。我们在Steiner建了一整家餐厅。哦天哪。你知道做什么会很棒吗？让我们做点什么，既然Graden在这里，让我们做一件事，让Thoreau永远被Waverly Inn禁止进入。就像你知道我的意思吗？
And don't let him know. You don't see Justin Thoreau anymore. Like he just, you're always busy, you're full, so we can get every other fucking time. Yeah, no, Con Ed has shut us down, yes. Yeah, but when we opened it, we wouldn't take reservations from the 203 area code, because that's Greenwich,
别让他知道。你再也见不到Justin Thoreau了。就像他只是，你总是很忙，你满了，所以我们可以得到其他所有该死的时间。是的，不，Con Ed把我们关了，是的。是的，但当我们开业时，我们不接受203区号的预订，因为那是格林威治，
and that's where all the hedge fund guys were. So we didn't want them. Con Ed, that's so good! So they make a reservation, we'd say, oh sorry, shut, you know, Con Ed. Like they're kind of all over the place. Listen Graydon, you're speaking our language. I have said many times, nobody is more responsible
那是所有对冲基金家伙所在的地方。所以我们不想要他们。Con Ed，太棒了！所以他们预订，我们会说，哦抱歉，关了，你知道，Con Ed。就像他们到处都是。听着Graydon，你在说我们的语言。我多次说过，没有人比那种私募股权家伙和银行家对这个星球的破坏负有更大的责任。他们绝对粗鲁。除了Dandies。除了Dandies，他是史上最伟大的人之一。其他人。史上最伟大的人之一。Double D。但我想要问你这个，
for the destruction of this planet than sort of private equity guys and bankers. They have absolutely rude. Except for Dandies. Except for Dandies, who is one of the all-time great guys. Everybody else. One of the all-time great guys. Double D. But I want to ask you this,
作为某种临别赠言，如果你愿意的话，你希望你的遗产是什么，如果你甚至考虑过这些术语的话？作为一个加拿大人，你可能从来没有。不，我的意思是，首先，我真的很自豪能成为加拿大人，尤其是现在，
as a sort of parting shot, if you will, what would you like your, because it's a tough one to answer, I'm sure, what would you like your legacy to be, if you've even thought in those terms? As a Canadian, you probably never have. No, I mean, first of all, I'm really proud of being a Canadian, and especially now,
我相信你也有同感。我喜欢Mark Carney。我认为你只是想离开，如果你到了一个海滩，那里到处都是糖果包装纸，我的倾向会是，我相信对你们来说也是一样，清理掉糖果包装纸，并试图留下比你到达时更好的东西。
I'm sure you feel the same way. I like Mark Carney. I think that you just want to leave, if you got to a beach and it's filled with candy wrappers, my inclination would be, and I'm sure for you guys as well, to sort of clean up the candy wrappers and try to leave something in better shape than when you got there.
在很大程度上，我们通过我们的孩子做到这一点。这是我的孩子，我为他们感到非常自豪，他们确实是好人，有趣且博学。这就是，因为那是你的遗产，因为他们会在你化为尘土之后继续存在。并在你身后留下适量体面的工作。是的，多么棒的回答。
And in a large part, we do that through our children. And it's my kids, I'm very proud of them, and they're truly good humans and funny and well-read. And that's, because that's your legacy, because they're going to go on after your turn to dust and all the rest of it. And leave a modest body of decent work behind you. Yeah, what a great answer.
是的，当然。嗯，听着，Graydon，非常感谢你今天加入我们。真是太荣幸了。我的意思是，我真的，我不知道。你是个伟大的人。荣幸的是我们。谢谢。
Yeah, for sure. Well, listen, Graydon, thank you so much for joining us today. Such an honor. I mean, I'm really, I don't know. You're a great man. The honor is ours. Thank you.
是的，我们一直是你的粉丝，我们之前谈论过你，我们三个，我们一直是你所做的一切的粉丝，从Spide套装到《名利场》再到Air Mail。现在你的书，《When the Going Was Good》，现在为我们所有的听众出版了。我们所有的听众？
Yeah, we've been such fans and we've spoken about you before, the three of us have, and we've been just a fan of everything you've done from Spide suits to Vanity Fair to Air Mail. And now your book, When the Going Was Good, is out now for all our listener. All our listener?
我们所有的听众。告诉他快点去买。或者她，或者她，或者他们，或者他们。我鼓励他或她或他们或无论那是谁，今天就出去买。Graydon，我们祝你持续成功，非常感谢。谢谢，Graydon。
All our listener. Tell him to get there quickly then. Or her, or her, or them, or them. I encourage him or her or them or whoever it is to go out and get it today. Graydon, we wish you nothing but continued success and thank you so much. Thank you, Graydon.
非常感谢你们，伙计们。是的，很高兴见到你，Graydon，是的。好的，荣幸。谢谢，Paul。干杯，再见。再见，伙计。不错的嘉宾，Willie。那很悲伤。现在，你知道不错的嘉宾，Willie。那是那个。
Thank you so much, guys. Yeah, nice to meet you, Graydon, yeah. Okay, pleasure. Thank you, Paul. Cheers, bye. Bye, buddy. Nice guest, Willie. That is sad. Now, you know Nice guest, Willie. That is that.
现在，你知道，再一次，每次我们有不是这些我们喜欢的大牌A级名人的人，我只是喜欢和其他人交谈。这太棒了。嗯，他，我的意思是，想想看，这是真的。不仅，Jay，你说了，我说了，John，你说了它的一个版本，他是一个潮流引领者，如果仅仅是因为他站在前线
Now, you know, again, every time we have somebody that is not one of these big fancy A-list celebs whom we love, I just love talking to other folks. It's great. Well, he, I mean, think about it, and it is true. Not only, and Jay, you said it, I said it, John, you said a version of it, that he was a tastemaker, if only because he was on the front lines
报道文化中正在发生的事情，无论是电影、电视、艺术还是媒体等等。但《名利场》。因为那个位置，他在很多方面最终引导了文化，因为他决定报道什么。以及什么是重要的，什么是值得关注的。Lorne Michaels仍然在做这件事。
of reporting what was happening culturally, whether it was a film or television or art or media, et cetera. But the vanity fair. Because of that position, he ends up, in a lot of ways, steering culture because of what he decides to report on. And what's in, what deserves attention. And Lorne Michaels is still doing it.
就像谁在主持《周六夜现场》，谁是音乐嘉宾，会告诉你谁是时代精神的顶峰。他和Lorne仍然在做这件事。再一次，我应该指出这些是加拿大人。而且我认为这其中有一些东西。新鲜的视角。
Like who's hosting Saturday Night Live and who's a musical guest will tell you who's the top of the zeitgeist. He and Lorne are still doing it. And again, I should be pointing out that these are Canadians. And I think that there's something to that. Fresh eyes.
嗯，加拿大人，我们只是在空间中占据了一个稍微高一点的地方。你有点断断续续。你是在经过峡谷吗？我失去你了。不，我有满格信号。关掉这个麦克风。你关掉这个麦克风。嗯，你知道吗？
Well, Canadians, we just inhabit just a slightly higher place in the space. You're breaking up a little bit. Are you going over a canyon? I'm losing you. No, I've got full bars. Shut off this mic. You turn off this mic. Well, you know what?
有这个，我之前谈论过这个。作为加拿大人，我们成长，我们在文化上和地理上都非常接近。所以我们是美国文化的观察者，以那种方式，非常接近。所以我们确实……等等，你认为那现在是什么，如果不是《名利场》，也许仍然是《名利场》
There is this, and I've spoken about this before. As Canadians, we grew up, we are so culturally close and geographically close. So we are kind of observers of American culture in that way and very close. And so we do- Wait, what do you think that is now though, if it's not Vanity Fair, maybe it still is Vanity Fair
那是所谓的潮流引领者。人们去哪里看？因为它现在看起来太碎片化了。是的，你是对的。嗯，你知道吗？它更多，我认为它已经被分成了这些不同的部分。在那个时代，《名利场》更像是一个大杂烩，占据了一个很大的空间。
that is the quote tastemaker. Like where do people look? Cause it seems so fragmented now. Yeah, you're right. Well, you know what? It's much more, I think that it's been divided into these different pieces. Vanity Fair was much more of a catch-all back at the time that inhabited a big space.
我不知道是否有任何东西占据了那么大的空间。除非是这个Airmail，我不知道。我认为很多播客也是。哦是的，那是真的。也许Smartless，也许Smartless播客。你知道，我没听过那个，但我听说过它，我听说它不太好。那是其中之一，它不太好。那是其中之一，它不太好。
I don't know if there's anything that inhabits that big. Unless it's this airmail, which I didn't know. I think a lot of podcasts do. Oh yeah, that's true. Maybe Smartless, maybe the Smartless podcast. You know, I haven't heard that, but I did hear about it, and I hear it's not great. That's one of the, it's not great. That's one of the things, it's not great.
我听说它被严重高估了。它被严重高估了，这些家伙，他们骂人太多，他们打断别人，但你知道他们真正掌握了什么吗？再见！把我们自己的再见作为再见。再见一整晚，再见！你是说他们如何在每集结束时说再见。再见！
It's a little overrated is what I'm hearing. It's very overrated, and these guys, they swear too much, they interrupt people, but you know what they do have really down pat? Bye! Reference our own bye as the bye. Bye all night, bye! You mean how they say goodbye at the end of each episode. Bye!
元！元太多了。元太多了。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。
Meta! Meta much. Meta much. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armgerve手工制作。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
更少。更聪明。更少。更聪明。更少。更聪明。更少。更聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armgerve. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
更少。更聪明。更少。更聪明。更少。更聪明。更少。更聪明。更少。并由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armgerve手工制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。